from morpheus to smith to even neo
himself old characters are back in new
forms in the matrix resurrections and
the movie's full of little moments that
will make you pause as you try to figure
out just what's going on
setting the stage for an unbelievably
meta first act the opening of the matrix
resurrections mirrors the opening of
1999's the matrix but not everything is
quite as it seems two new characters
hackers bugs and seek are also on the
scene and they like the audience know
this scene and know that something is
off as we move to the introduction of
trinity we see bugs observing but pause
the moment and you'll realize early that
this is not carriane moss and this is
very much not the opening of the matrix
bugs realizes it too but pause on an
earlier frame and you'll be one step
ahead of the game this reveal leads to
the scene branching off from the events
of the original movie and eventually
revealing the entire intro takes place
within a modal inside the matrix inside
the world of the matrix a modal is a
testing sandbox that exists isolated
from a program while still using the
code of that program for example the
modal neo creates in the film exists
within a game that he's designed another
bonus pause comes when bugs must flee
the scene on the way out she crashes
into a neon marquee marked anderson's a
dead giveaway that we are in a model
created by neo himself a fact that isn't
revealed until a little bit later
after being discovered by agents while
peeping on the faux trinity intro bugs
finds herself being chased by the
program that will soon be revealed to
her to be morpheus in a room full of
keys and yes this is 100 a reference to
the key maker from reloaded she finds a
door to another room in the modal where
she ends up confronting the program as
it turns out he has been here before
this is where it all began we are in
thomas anderson's room from the start of
the matrix the room is a replica of
neo's cramped hacker apartment and
everything in it if you pause the movie
for certain frames during the scene you
can look around and experience quite a
bit of nostalgia full of knickknacks and
callbacks this sequence shows on full
display just how dense with meaning the
sets and resurrections are you can see a
replica of neo's old computer still
intact at a certain point bugs picks up
the old metacortex id marked thomas
anderson every detail down to the same
poster on the wall and open bottles and
cans of coke littered around the
microwave is intact this scene holds
another crucial moment in it bugs
confirms the program to be a morpheus
subconsciously created by neo within the
matrix thus understanding the one is
still alive and closer than anyone
realized
in a scene where bugs is explaining her
motivations for pursuing neo and freeing
him we are shown a very pause-worthy
flashback as bugs explains it we see her
washing a skyscraper window then from
atop the building neo is seen jumping
off but for split second we see an image
of an old man in his place as he turns
to bugs he's once again the bearded
keanu reeves that we know and love as
neo in the matrix resurrections this
moment gave bugs hope and proved neo was
still out there somewhere this sets her
character arc into motion paralleling
the arc of morpheus in the original
matrix this moment is the first clue the
film gives about a twist that is yet to
come later we come to understand this
moment as bugs seeing neo in his true
form not the old man that the rest of
the residents of the matrix see him as
throughout the movie up until the reveal
there are shots of the man everyone sees
him in reflections that hint at the
truth late in the film it is revealed by
the analyst that this sighting was
actually a previous escape attempt by
neo
if you managed to avoid all marketing
material for resurrections beyond the
initial trailer you probably found
yourself shocked by the reveal of
jonathan groff's character to be agent
smith this is especially surprising
since the movie intentionally misled the
audience by not casting hugo weaving in
the role that he immortalized even if
you knew groff's true role going in the
moment where he finally goes mask off
and shouts mr anderson in his best hugo
weaving voice is one of the most spine
chilling moments of the film the
shootout that ensues is stylish fast and
features a whole lot of yaya abdul
mateen the second looking sweet in a
suit and some sick gun kata later on the
reason for smith's role in neo-simulated
life is explained re-watching the movie
a must do for matrix fans with an hbo
max subscription it is easy to see that
smith was placed as thomas anderson's
business partner to keep neo in check
this allowed the analysts to be able to
observe neo at all times
one pill makes you larger and one pill
makes you small sure you've probably
heard jefferson airplanes white rabbit
countless times in the marketing run up
to the release of resurrections but it
really is a perfect song to score the
return to the matrix the pivotal scene
where neo finally takes the red pill
again is dense with callbacks to the
first movie the setting is incredible
neo enters a room that closely resembles
the abandoned building where he took the
red pill in the first movie and on the
projection screen behind him that is
lining the wall the original scene from
the 1999 matrix is playing on a loop it
is a huge meta moment for the movie one
that brings into question the themes of
choice and repetition
nothing comforts anxiety like
little nostalgia
when morpheus says this on the nose line
he is both referring to the more
comfortable environment he and bugs
created to coerce neo into taking the
red pill and also making a meta
commentary on this sequel's mere
existence neo has been here before in
the words of the oracle he has already
made the choice through this scene and
many more filmmaker lana wachowski
analyzes the pervasiveness of franchises
and reboots by resurrecting past scenes
characters and motifs to interrogate how
her work was interpreted and what people
want out of a matrix sequel versus what
she wants to convey
after returning to real life neo is
immediately jacked back in and like in
the 1999 original is transported to a
pure white room the construct where
morpheus awaits his arrival
i remember this
in resurrections this is where morpheus
explains what exactly he is an algorithm
written by neo that is in fact
constructed from the memories of both
morpheus and agent smith from here of
course we must move to the dojo the
training dojo where the epic neo and
morpheus fight occurs in the matrix
makes a return in resurrections the
fight that ensues between neo and this
new version of morpheus mirrors the
original but the stakes are raised in
this scene if neo can't find the power
in himself to win he will die morpheus
almost defeats neo while the ex-master
of kung fu lies on the ground morpheus
reminds him of the one thing he is
fighting for trinity this results in neo
finally regaining his matrix superpowers
or at least some of them and turning the
whole dojo into a bright supernova thus
passing the test and waking him up
while pretty much the entire first half
of the matrix resurrections acts as an
homage to and deconstruction of the
original matrix movie the film is also a
direct sequel to the matrix revolutions
along with her co-writers lana wachowski
decided to bring back some of the
primary characters from the sequels
including morpheus's old flame and butt
kicking captain niobe and everyone's
favorite scene-chewing program the
merovingian
right
speaking of merv as trinity so glibly
nicknamed him in the matrix revolutions
the frenchman himself makes a return in
resurrections the exiled program is in a
haggard state though his beard and grimy
appearance are a polar opposite from the
way we see him present in the first two
sequels blaming neo for his decrepit
state he goes on a fourth wall breaking
rant about the digital age including a
great moment of lamenting how style and
great conversation has been replaced by
the beep beep beep beep beep of
incessant texting we can't repeat what
he calls wikipedia but the very direct
reference to social media as face zucker
suck is the highlight of the rant
granted you can't hear it when paused
but that line alone is worth rewinding
to hear again
probably the single best woe moment of
the matrix resurrections comes at the
very end and it is well worth the wait
in the climactic moment of the film neo
and trinity clench hands and jump off of
a rooftop this leap of faith is a fake
out the whole movie fans have been
waiting for neo to regain his ability to
fly and this feels like the moment it is
about to happen and then it doesn't not
quite after their leap neo begins to
fall and then he's caught the camera
pans up to show that this time it is
trinity who has the power of flight it
is an awe-inspiring shot that
single-handedly gives trinity fans the
best moment they didn't even know they
wanted the entire movie is a tribute to
carrie anne moss and trinity as much as
it is one to neo and keanu reeves for
the two of them the end of resurrections
is only a new beginning for the rest of
us well we will just have to wait and
see check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies and tv shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]